this is the first time that we've seen
28 year old Brian Coburg the suspect in
these murders in court he was arrested
in the middle of the night on Friday
last week at his family's home in
Pennsylvania which where he'd been
staying during the Christmas period it's
more than 2 500 miles away you can see
Brian coburger there it's more than 2
500 miles away
um from the scene of the crime which he
is suspected of having committed in
Moscow Idaho he's a suspect in the
killings of four University students
three girls who lived at the house that
you can see on your screen now Madison
Mogan Kaylee gonsalves and Zana canodle
and Zana canodle's boyfriend Ethan
Chapin he's a he's accused of stabbing
them to death in their beds in the
middle of night in the middle of
November you can see the victims there
on your screen all aged between 20 and
21 years old Brian coburger appeared in
court today charged with four counts of
murder this was an extradition hearing
this is about the the authorities being
able to transport him from Pennsylvania
you see him there arriving in court this
afternoon to Moscow Idaho uh where the
authorities want him to stand trial for
their murders he signed this document
voluntarily he came into court and
briefly made eye contact with his family
who was sitting in the front row were
told by our colleagues who were inside
that court that his mother began to cry
she was comforted by uh by his sister
and a deputy inside that Court brought
them tissues he will now be transferred
within the next 10 days to Idaho once
he's there we'll learn more about why
he's suspected of having committed this
crime when the arrest affidavit is
unsealed so the families of those
victims we expect to be inside Court in
Idaho when Brian coburger arrives there
when we'll learn more about why he's
suspected of having committed these
crimes we'll keep an eye out for that
Martha thank you